[Music]
well hello
reject vil i'm greg alba and i'm amber
plaster amber plaster from the amber
plaster channel after buzz tv some shows
she watches and she also has social
media content amber
so many people have asked me to check
out tom holland's lip sync battle seen
in the rain umbrella umbrella ella
all right let's watch this and uh with
the song and everything those videos are
gonna so be monetized i can't wait oh
yeah
i can't hear
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i come from bed you know i could be
more prepared a little bit more
[Music]
you're ready you're ready
because i have been talking a lot of
trash to each other yeah you should go
the more i talk to you the more nervous
i make myself
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
i like that
[Applause]
how did you put makeup on
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
oh it's on a holland
[Music]
i know we
[Music]
yes
[Music]
look at those arms
look at those thighs
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow he really prepared for this
[Music]
come on do a flip you can do a flip
you can flip and chase like gymnastics
and water
yeah okay
okay
i'm like kind of turned off yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
tom holland whoa
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's chrissy
what happened there chrissy teigen what
second performance uh i think we should
do it i want to see what happened with
there
i was gonna kiss her
[Music]
thank you oh my god
you are soaking wet
doing one of my favorite songs of all
time
i just wanted to see if it's possible
that i live out one of my biggest
fantasies
[Applause]
her husband is like hey
[Applause]
[Music]
tom holland should have kissed her yeah
[Applause]
that's our new spider man
slinging and doing what you do in tights
and then dancing around here with this
unbelievable outfit on
well you know i whistling unbelievable
[Applause]
honestly
that was incredible
[Music]
on your way back to the vip
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to do a second performance i think so
let's stop it wow
oh that's part of the mtv movie awards
oh
because zendaya is in spider-man as well
tom holland turned me on
like woman tom holland or transgender
tom hall
both i don't know i'm confused i feel
like he is a child and yet now i
i am attracted to him yeah um her i
don't know
whatever that was i mean he's a legal
adult so we can say that okay he is a
legal adult but the first movie i saw
him in was the impossible where he was a
kid
that's when i was really attracted
it's a joke i don't want to put that in
there
but it's going in the video it's okay
he's an adult now i can say it that
doesn't make that thought any better do
you see what i have to do is shirtless
for most of the impossible as he's
surviving the hurricane i met tom
holland once you did
yeah it was actually one of the saddest
moments of my life see there's this much
bigger reaction or dude named tyrone
magnus
and uh never heard of him well good and
keep it and i can say that honestly and
now i'm relishing it tyrone magnus did a
uh video reaction as captain america
civil war where tom hall made his first
appearance in the marvel civil rights
universe tyron magnus visits california
the one week he's out here we're walking
down the street somewhere
suddenly this big escalade pulls over on
the sidewalk outruns tom holland and
he's like oh you tyrone magnus and
and then he's like yeah because he
didn't talk tyrone didn't even recognize
him
he's like i'm tom holman
and i freak out because i know who he is
i'm like you're tall i look like i
freaked out but he didn't even give me
the lie today i showed your video to the
russo brothers who did uh civil war oh
and they loved it they like he said he
said this to tyrone
he's like can i have a picture with you
so tom holland
asked tyrone magnus for a picture
oh
and that picture that's on instagram i
took that photo and he didn't even shake
my hand
he was just star struck it's okay i mean
he probably thought i was just tyrone's
like little groupie buddy who was like
yeah i'm hanging out with famous youtube
sensation tyrone magnets right now but
now he's gonna know that we reviewed his
little lip sync dance maybe and maybe
he'll like it if you maybe he won't tell
you what tom holland if if if i forgive
you
it'll be because you let me have sex
with you dressed as how you were dressed
here this is going well i think it's
going really well i would let him shoot
his spiderwebs
you're just digging yourself in a hole
it's this video is not monetized with
the song anyway i could say whatever the
hell i wanted at this point i feel like
i
enjoyed the redirect from the beginning
of like the slow singing and the rang
song but i was not expecting him to come
out with full face of makeup on after
like 30 seconds of being behind the
screen so i was kind of impressed with
that that's anything it's crazy how much
preparation he had to do for a dance
routine in order to help promote
spider-man homecoming yeah what
celebrities have to do now to promote
movies well it's like they like they did
that back in the day like to a lesser
extent on trl they would have like
actors come on and be like they're the
new spider-man here are his emo bangs
check it out i know but it's like this
is this this must have been like at
least a week of preparation that's true
for like snl and stuff he's probably
gonna be on snow i hope so and so she i
hope so she's cute too yeah am i allowed
to say that i think she's 12 but
you can't compliment anyone under the
age of 18
even if it's not sexual you can't say it
it feels wrong somehow uh yeah this was
like a kind of like a junior version of
lipstick battle like right yeah i mean
they just look really young they're
playing high schoolers but i'm pretty
sure they might be 27 yeah
but they look like they're 12. so we're
gonna treat them like we're told just to
cover the bases absolutely i was telling
amber before we film that i like this
version of lip sync battle way more than
jimmy fallon's because i feel like jimmy
fallon's is simple it's like
okay what song does a celebrity know
let's have them pretend to sing it to me
that's not even like a limp sing battle
it's just like a segment of his show
where
they
try to embarrass one another yeah it's
kind of funny honestly i get kind of
bored i like it when he does the um when
he has the um
oh carpool karaoke he's not even no
that's james corden that's cool because
they're singing along to their own songs
i guess i like james corden yeah yeah
but this is really cool too because i
mean this is like a full dance routine
you get to see celebrities dress up and
be all weird the one with channing tatum
is really good too
i didn't watch that more than once it's
fine it's fine
all right well thanks for everyone who
recommended this video you can subscribe
to the real rejects yeah recently
watched the patreon got exclusive video
content on there i've been receiving a
lot of support from you guys over at
patreon helping support the channel
really really love all you got like a
lot of new patrons this week actually
too oh yeah community's growing
[ __ ] what i like about because
i have a patreon as well is that they
seem to be the same people who are
always like
the best commenters and people who have
been with you for the longest time so i
always get excited when i have new
patrons because it's usually not people
who are strangers yeah it's usually
people like oh man i remember you from
like five years ago exactly that's why
it's kind of cool they're the most
dedicated supporters they are they're
the better ones
they're like the most dedicated
supporters and uh even the ones like i
especially love the ones who
are always like i don't have any money
but they they contribute but like a
dollar yeah
it doesn't matter it health totally
matters yeah and you still get perks
with it too yeah yeah i think i think uh
whatever amount is it made whenever you
see a dollar i every time i see someone
becoming a patron i say an out loud
gratitude
it you know yeah to the universe amber
blaster
is on the amber plaster channel where
she's constantly getting plastered she's
on after buzz tv follow her on social
media her hair is green for the next
couple months it's okay she looks like
the joker cause you're pale
the green hair and purple
i'm like i'm just wondering if you when
you showed up did you know that you have
like a joker thing yeah okay good i
didn't know if it was like an honey i
like looked in the mirror and i was like
what goes good with green hair cause i
still don't know how to dress for a
green head i'm used to being a redhead
whatever so i'm like oh maybe blue blue
will look good i was like i look like
the joker and i was like well it'll look
good on camera oh well
purple is just joker's looking at going
with the vibe trying to make it happen i
think it's super sexy and your husband's
a lucky guy thanks
he must be so sexually satisfied we're
cutting the camera
you